今日は僕2
始めたいやーどうも久しぶりだみんなの主婦国は以前とある実験をしただそう
巨大スーパーボールを作るんです何かスーパーボルダー2
自分でも作れると聞いたので限界までたくさんの場でやってみたら
大失敗でしたあらゆるに俺思ったんだけどもう何がと見たとしたら
自家製のスーパーボウル2の職人が作ったわけじゃないから
所詮は素人のスーパーボウルが素人が作ったら同社はないから眠り私はそういう実験
結果にたどり着い
今日は違うよ今回は普通に市販のスーパーボールを撮影しました
これは第二部4えーっ
ん
えっっ
みたい剣でこの市販のスーパーボウルはとても小さい国目指したとるんですだから今回
は家版のスーパーボールをできるだけ買ってみました
super doll たくさん空軍はなかなか恥ずかしかったね存在の実験は
なぁ初代は変わりません巨大製パンフォローを作るわけなんですけどもう今だよこれを
告げるというよりするファンテープくっつけば
とりあえずは俺はで回数バブルを作りたいその一心だからもう見た目とかはどうでも
いいんだよ
だから理想としてはこいつらを全部固めて一つにそれ用超薄い透明な水の判定日で包む
そうすることによって私の理論によると南力を損なわずに巨大なスーパーボウルが
作れると思っていますこんなは全部頑張って何とか一羽の目にして
ブーブー言っ女性
うまく丸にしてみますはいここああああ落ちる
ほらなぜで作ってなくてここでクーペねえだろお前たちゃスーパーじゃなければただの
ゴールだ
神根空虚しスペインなくてフーパー
ブーブーるー結構引田てきました
もう一で頑張れてことです
ええええええ
をします
べきましたーーーつげきましたそーねえ o 脚ガンガン兄も max まで閉めつき
ましたテープでこれはやばいな
それはもう本物ですは前年の巨大スーパーボウルの克服がついに
べきそうでございます余裕仕返しのとっきーだした乗るぞ
全力でさせてくれこれでもうちゃんピンでしたらもう
のかチラッつい21
ten
持っています